at some points it isn't politics in the
genuine sense of the word should be at
the service of the personal it should
help every if we believe that it is our
right to life liberty and pursuit of
happiness then politics should be at the
service of that for every single
individual on that level what Obama and
Clinton we're talking about last night
about healthcare or education or or you
know what they will do for us all of it
relates to our personal lives and in
that sense yes what I am very afraid of
is not political in that sense that you
as an individual are very aware and
alert of whether the government is
working in the interests of the Indians
you know what I'm worried about is that
politicization where everything you do
you do for an agenda either for or
against an agenda which is what I see
more in this country I don't see
political in the noble sense of the word
I see political in the crassest former
you